por el momento esperan son soldados del
ejército ucraniano no muy lejos de aquí
a unos 20 kilómetros está la frontera
con rusia por supuesto esto puede
convertirse en un gran conflicto sabemos
que rusia ha traído muchas tropas nos
preparamos estamos listos
como en una guerra de otra época estos
soldados ucranianos hacen guardia dentro
de trincheras estas últimas semanas el
ejército ruso ha movilizado a decenas de
miles de soldados en la frontera aquí
los enfrentamientos con los rebeldes pro
rusos son casi diarios y las minas
invaden toda la zona a pesar del apoyo
verbal de las potencias occidentales a
ucrania estos soldados prefieren contar
con ellos mismos si creen todos los
países que nos apoyan en eeuu y los
demás
pienso que no deberíamos contar
demasiado con su ayuda debemos
concentrarnos en nuestras propias
fuerzas qué país querría enviar a sus
ciudadanos si me permiten que lo diga
así a la muerte
el conflicto entre separatistas que
rusos apoyados por moscú y el ejército
ucraniano deja desde 2014 más de 13.000
muertos este sábado la marina rusa se
acercó un paso más y se desplazó hacia
el mar negro